welcome back in this lesson we're going
to go over online customer acquisition
techniques you can achieve many
different goals with online advertising
but we'll be focusing on customer
acquisition rather than Brenda where
news for example so we're going to
divide this lesson into two parts now in
the first half we're going to talk about
paid tools to acquire new customers such
as sem programmatic media buying
affiliate marketing social media
marketing which includes video marketing
then we'll go into free customer
acquisition tools and talk about
engaging with your community and inbound
marketing including content generation
and email marketing so let's get started
with some background information about
the three engines of growth